whether you like it hot
sweet or savory a good sauce adds that
extra kick
to any meal where's the water here are
some spicy secrets behind this special
sauce
i don't think there is a contradiction
between
a simple life and a spicy food
perhaps someone who's living a simple
life
needs to have something to spice it up
maybe that works
my name is father richard walds and i am
a monk of subiaco abbey
which is a monastery in subiaco arkansas
after i graduated from high school i
entered the monastery
so i've been 55 years a month
[Applause]
monk sauce which we produce here at
tsubiaku abbey
is an habanero pepper sauce we call that
monk sauce because it's monk made
anybody who has handled habanero peppers
knows that you should not be doing this
without a
glove on a good monk
is a good balance between prayer
and work
it ought to be done you want to find out
if it's any good
[Music]
where's the water huh
i suspect that a lot of people have kind
of fanciful ideas about
monks and what they do and they get into
the monastery and they find out that
monks are
very much like everybody else
[Music]
i feel very close connection
to the land in this area
the longer that i was here the more i
realized that god
got me here because he knew how to be in
a community
the community is a very important thing
to me
ketchup so american it's basically the
red in red white and blue right
and that red clearly is from the
tomatoes the ketchup is made from
but that wasn't always the case the
first recorded recipe for ketchup
comes from china and for more than a
thousand years
it wasn't even made with tomatoes
it was made with fish guts
[Applause]
[Music]
fish intestines bladder and stomach all
mixed together with salt
then sealed and heated in the hot summer
sun for 20 days
that was the original ketchup a
fermented fish paste that dates back to
6th century china
it was popular throughout southeast asia
and british and dutch settlers who
arrived in the 1600s
loved this stuff over time they brought
ketchup home to europe and added their
own modifications
including beer mushrooms walnuts oysters
strawberries and peaches
by the mid-1700s english ketchup was a
mainstay on british dinner tables and as
colonists went west
it soon made its way across the pond
that's
where tomatoes come in they're native to
the americas
and it's rumored europeans once believed
they were poisonous
but poisonous they were not
in 1812 a philadelphia horticulturalist
and scientist by the name of james mease
introduced tomatoes into the mix
he published a tomato ketchup recipe
that was the beginning of a new
crimson era from there many different
iterations were concocted
and by the end of the 18th century the
new york tribune called tomato ketchup
america's national condiment that was on
every table in the land
which brings us back to this tomato
ketchup is here to stay
and i for one don't miss the fish guts
[Music]
everyone loves sauce but in korea there
is one sauce that goes on everything
gojujeng it's tangy it's sweet it's
spicy
and in korea no one makes it better than
the people in this small town
welcome to sunchang
[Music]
she's been making gojujeng for 40 years
on gets its taste
from fermented soybean bricks sun chang
village has a naturally humid climate
that is perfect for fermenting the beans
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
to be forgotten so she offers workshops
to visitors
in the hopes they will learn how to make
her special sauce and continue the
gojijang tradition
[Music]
of
foreign
[Music]
you remember this can the sweet sauce
the soft noodle
this was childhood but did you know that
chef boyardee was an actual chef
he was his name was hector and he made a
mean
pasta sauce but it wasn't hector sauce
that made chef boyardee the household
name that it is today
you can thank the u.s military for that
in the 1930s
hector berti opened up an italian
restaurant in ohio and everyone was like
oh my god i love your sauce so he
started selling it
and he sold a lot of it a lot a lot
by 1938 he had opened up his own factory
selling his sauce and pasta
can ask for chef boyardee's spaghetti
dinner only about
15 cents a serving then world war ii
happened and a phone call was made
u.s military called hector had said
something like help make food for the
troops
he already had the canning
infrastructure so hector said all right
his company shifted from a civilian
consumer base to a military one
chef rd became the largest supplier of
rations to us and allied forces
production was happening 24 7. by the
end of the war the factory was too large
and the military demand no longer
existed hector didn't know what to do
so he sold it to this large company
called american home products who were
all like
we got this they quickly rebranded and
distributed the can as easy to make at
home meals and filled supermarket
shelves across the united states
so today when we buy chef boyardee we're
actually eating rebranded world war
ii field rations yep
it's part of the secret sauce in your
big mac
the condiment in your reuben it's creamy
yet tangy
zesty and named after a breathtaking
part of new york state
i'm talking about thousand island
dressing the origin of thousand island
dressing traces back to the highest
ranks of american society how did it all
come to be
well that's where things get interesting
two tales lie at the heart of the
thousand island dressing dispute
there is alan benus former owner of the
thousand island
inn where he claims the dressing was
first served to the public
and then there's george bolt a legendary
hotelier
whose chef created the dressing and had
it served at his hotels
we tracked down a george bolt expert to
explain his story
george bolt was a russian immigrant he
rose to
one of the most prominent hotel men of
the nation
he also loved to vacation in the
thousand islands
one day mr boat and his wife louise were
taking a
boat ride on one of their yachts and the
chef on board forgot
salad dressing so he improvised and
created what became to be known as
thousand allen dressing he loved the
dressing so much he began serving it
at the wall of historia hotel in new
york city but according to the other guy
alan bienis it's nothing but hearsay the
dressing was
originated by the wife of a clayton
fishing guide
named sophia lalone she gave the recipe
to the original owners of the hotel
where it was first served to the dining
public
after we purchased the hotel and going
through looking at everything
in the safe was a sheet of paper with a
recipe on it
and i wasn't sure what it was i took it
out to our
kitchen staff and the head cook said it
looks to me like a recipe for thousand
islands dressing
so will we ever learn the truth nothing
is more popular than
competing legends or as delicious